during the pandemic i've been asking
everyone the same first question so i'd
like to ask you guys
what tv series would you love to guest
star on oh
what we do in the shadows yeah the west
wing i think
island that would be new one no okay
well there you go
uh i am curious i was looking at jake
and i i almost thought you were doing a
brady bunch thing
looking up at the other window i don't
know
[Laughter]
for each of you um have you ever been
asked by a director you really need to
get this
in one take
yeah so what was the what was the last
time someone said to you we really need
you to do this in one take
well you know what actually i don't know
if it's directly that but i mean it
depends because there there are
situations where you have
20 minutes right and we're losing
they're losing the light like when
you're doing the kids are all right and
and josh patrick and i were playing ping
pong it was like we just didn't have
we we literally had 20 minutes we're
playing a ping pong game and doing a
scene so we've got to get this because
that's all we have
um but then there are there up there are
times when people are doing like a
long when there's a long in you know
uninterrupted camera move and
that so there's that kind of it's like
we need you to just do it you know
all the way through you just described
every movie i've ever made
literally i don't know i was like you're
like have you ever done
literally that's the only movies i've
ever done that
i remember doing in uh donnie darko
uh the opening shot of the movie is
was we had one one opportunity to do it
uh for sunrise and it was one take
and we we shot it at the
before pre-production um we had to all
wake up i remember like two a.m and
drive out to the angels crest forest up
to the top of this mountain and we had
one take it was a steady camp
and then there was a camera problem
which we didn't learn about until
three or four days after when the day
elise were exposed and we had to go back
in the middle of shooting again on a
random day and reshoot the opening of
the movie because we could only shoot it
in one take with a particular
kind of light before i run into time i
gotta ask you one question about the
movie for each of you what was it about
this script this story that said i want
to be a part of this
i love that it was about a little girl
you know a little girl in her adventure
and and how the adventure sort of led
her to finding herself
and reconnecting with her father and
remembering her mother i was very
touched by that
i would agree with julian and i would
also just say that
i think you know some of my favorite
stories particularly
children's stories have a dark side to
them and this one has a sense of
sort of uh pain and longing of the loss
of a parent
and then you know reconciliation and
healing and i was really moved by that
too but
but that the little girl was the reason
that all these people
uh could see themselves and change you
know really really moved me
um because i think it is in the end all
about those
who you know come after us and
and that's what this movie's about how
they teach us
that note i gotta go uh congrats i hope
you guys are both doing
you know i hope everything goes well for
you guys in the you know upcoming future
same two man thanks bud cool have a
great day